new footage has just emerged of
sayfudine risky you can see that footage
now carrying his gun on the beach in
soos we're about to see him go behind
that tree he'll reimagine just the
moment this footage was filmed by a
Czech holidaymaker he was staying one of
the nearby hotels at the time of the
attack and you'll remember of course
that the 23 year old that you can now
see in the middle of your screen there
killed 38 people with the gun that he's
carrying there in his right hand
30 of them British let's bring in our
senior correspondent Ian woods who's
looking at these pictures in is it
possible to establish it what stage of
the attack these pictures were taken I
think this is the latter stage of the
the attack because there's a reason now
for the holidaymaker to film something
this attack lasted for more than than
half an hour and people were carrying in
their rooms and looking out back onto
the beach and this appears to be the the
later stages
perhaps a few minutes before he was then
driven off the beach by 2 News Ian's and
then tracked by the police and shot and
killed in an alleyway that behind the
hotel this to my knowledge I think is
the 3rd different piece of video that
has emerged off the gunman on the beach
one is a shot which shows him running
from the sea towards the hotel again in
the latter stages of the attack there's
the other famous one which was obtained
exclusively by Sky News when we see a
hotel worker filming what is going on
after the initial gunfire and while resi
is still marauding his way through the
hotel and he picks up an olive bottle of
olive oil to try to attack a minute you
get a sense of Tunisians trying to drive
him away from the hotel and protecting
holidaymakers so this is the third piece
of footage which is coming out now and I
think the very fact that you can't see
anybody else in in shot there suggests
that the attack has happened people have
run away from the scene
locals are perhaps forming the line of
that we have seen behind him and trying
to sort of push him away from the hotel
so it doesn't pretty clear anything new
to our version of events I don't think
but still chilly nonetheless to see him
walking around so I want to say
aimlessly but clearly he had a murderous
intent but so Moulton Utley casually
exactly and although you say it doesn't
necessarily add to our knowledge of the
sequence of events presumably any
footage that the security services can
get their hands on in Tunisia and in
Britain as well will be very closely
analyzed because there are still a lot
of unanswered questions aren't there
still some suggestions that he may not
have been acting alone
yeah the reports from from several
British holidaymakers that they believe
that there had been a a second
government we don't know whether that
was simply confusion with with security
forces or or or what but certainly the
Tunisians have always said that he acted
alone on the beach this footage as you
say comes from a Czech holiday maker it
may be that it's only emerging now
because it's only now that the Czech
holiday maker has has gone home and has
uploaded it or whatever certainly a lot
of the British holiday makers in fact
almost all the British holiday makers
who were coming home from the Tunisian
resorts were questioned by the police
when they got to the other end is find
out if they have any information if they
had any photographs that they had any
video to be able to build up this this
picture
it's clearly a Tunisian investigation
which will be going on into the identity
of possible accomplices but the British
authorities still have to put together
as accurate a picture as they can of
what happened to each of the individual
fatalities because an inquest will be
held in due course possibly it will take
several years for it all to come
together but they will want to establish
how he killed each of the holidaymakers
whether it was on the beach where the
massacre began near the swimming pool
where he emerged and walked through and
then he walked through the hotel out of
the reception and out to the front gates
of the hotel on the other side and was
still killing people on the other side
of the hotel as well so they want to try
to build up as much of a picture as they
can as to how each of those individual
people were killed